this is a two-pronged uh vaccine that
gives protection against both the
original 2020 strain and omicron and in
fact the mhra says that it gives a much
better immune response
against omicron which of course has
dominated the infections through 2022
and is likely to continue doing so in
the coming months but the jcvi is much
more sniffy about the the clinical
evidence it says that the
the immune response against some
variants is marginally higher and that
the clinical relevance is uncertain so
when you look at its list yes it's there
alongside the the current uh pfizer and
moderna
boosters that we've been using up until
now and indeed one from novavax as well
but the gcvi says it would be much
better
if the same type of booster was used
throughout this autumn rather than
rather than sort of mixing things around
and that because modern can't be sure
that it can provide all 26 million doses
that will be required here in the uk let
alone the millions required in europe
and elsewhere
that is why i think uh the the jcvi is a
little bit cautious about this vaccine
it's saying that it's much better to get
a booster in time before resurgent
infections that's more important than
the exact dose the the kind of vaccine
boosting that you have